I remember that show like it was
yesterday we first met Melissa Joan Hart
as a teenager on Nickelodeon's hit 90
sitcom Clarissa explains it all the 43
year old has kept her Hollywood career
going all while raising her three boys
well melissa is making her next big move
a family one and PT got the invite to
join them in Africa for a good works
mission hey ETF Melissa Joan Hart here
with my husband Mark and my son Mason we
are in Zambia and we are guests of World
Vision so thanks for joining us Vaalu
box
well I've wanted to go to Africa since I
was really little and as far as the
mission part goes then I said this is a
mission trip not a safari and what did
you say I want to go he's like I'm there
I'm doing it
this is your weekend loose whoa okay
the trio got right to work in this
remote African village Melissa and her
family have sponsored these three
sisters aged 6 to 13 they also brought
much-needed supplies for their entire
village we brought them toys and
necessities socks and food the goats are
the the really big thing that makes a
big change so that they can you know
then learn to farm and then teach others
and share the goats Mason brought like
five footballs and they taught the kids
how to throw properly told me I wish you
would look at me the way some of these
kids look at me when I show you how to
do something instead of just going I got
it dad one of the most powerful yet
heartbreaking moments was meeting this
three year old girl Maria she had gone
maybe the first year of her life with
really bad nutrition and now she's three
years old and still the size of a
one-year-old she's starting to put on
weight finally but she's just not
absorbing the nutrition and you know
they're really straight really worried
about her and concerned about her by
making the trip to Africa Melissa hopes
others will be inspired to help those in
need you can sponsor a child or you can
just send a family a goat you can send a
family a bicycle so those girls can get
to school or the mom can bring the crops
in to market in our world it's not that
much to to make a huge difference in
their lives and for more information on
how you can help go to World Vision org
[Applause]
[Music]